madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les
Députés le propre de toute société
humaine c'est de regarder en face
l'avenir qui se dessine devant elle
interroger son modèle puiser en soi les
ressources suffisante pour avancer
corriger ce qui doit l'être construire
les bonnes solutions une société ne se
perd jamais quand elle cherche à avancer
une société ne se perd jamais quand elle
doute elle perd quand le doute l'emporte
sur tout le reste quand le doute glace
quand il fige quand il conduit à douter
non pas de l'avenir qui se dessine mais
à douter de soi-même de ses forces de
ses
capacités je suis
né je suis né en
1989 l'année du bicentenaire de la
Révolution une année 89 où l'on a cru
que la démocratie libérale et le progrès
universel triompheraient par eux-mêmes
ma génération a vu l'inverse se produire
parce que notre génération partout dans
le monde voit son monde chambouler plus
fortement encore que tout autre avant
elle elle est en proie aux doutes doute
sur l'avenir de sa planète doute sur son
identité doute ici en France sur qui
nous sommes comme peuple et comme nation
doute sur notre modèle social sur nos
services publics sur notre
démocratie notre responsabilité celle de
chacune et chacun d'entre nous c'est de
puiser en nous la force d'identifier
tous les ressorts pour les surpasser si
nous sommes là ici réunis si nous nous
engageons par-dà nos divergences et nos
désaccords c'est que nous avons un point
commun partagé par des dizaines de
millions de nos concitoyens nous voyons
davantage de raisons d'espérer que de
douter c'est parce que nous sommes prêts
à affronter pour avancer affronter pour
avancer mesdames et messieurs les
députés mesdames et messieurs les
députés en m'exprimant face à vous c'est
en réalité à chaque citoyen de notre
pays que je m'adresse et à travers vous
c'est à chacun de nos concitoyens que je
veux le dire nous ne sommes pas
n'importe quel pays la France n'a jamais
été n'est pas ne sera jamais une nation
qui subit ni hier ni aujourd'hui ni
demain dans les pires moments de doute
de désarroi de désunion elle a montré sa
solidité son supplément d'âme qui fait
d'elle une nation à nul autre pareil en
cette année 2024 nous commémorerons les
80 ans du débarquement moment de
libération d'une France de soutien à des
Français qui pour la plupart n'avaient
jamais cessé de croire en elle en cette
ané 2024 nous rouvrirons les portes de
Notre-Dame de Paris alors que l'image
rétinienne des flammes reste si vive
dans l'esprit des
Français en cette année 2024 nous
accueillerons le monde un monde
bouleversé un monde divisé oui nous
accueillerons le monde à l'occasion des
Jeux Olympiques et
paralympies la France rime avec
puissance la France c'est unère idéal
c'est un patrimoine témoin d'une
histoire millénaire c'est un héritage
moral celui de la patrie où sont nés les
droits de l'homme celui d'un modèle
social protecteur envié dans le monde
entier la
France la France c'est le pays de la
création que nous soutenons et qui nous
fait rayonner c'est la patrie de la
recherche à laquelle nous donnons des
moyens sans précédent c'est la nation de
l'innovation qui construit le monde de
demain de 2030
la France ce sont nos jeunes qui osent
et qui se lancent la France ce sont nos
familles et toutes ces mères
célibataires qui se battent qui ne
lâchent rien
jamais ce sont nos soignants nos
professeurs nos forces de l'ordre tous
nos agents publics nos militair qui
s'engagent pour quelque chose qui les
dépasse ce sont nos artisans qui font
rayonner nos savoir-faire nos
agriculteurs nos pêcheurs qui travaille
matin midi et soir pour nous
nourrir
ce
sont ce sont nos élus locaux et je suis
l'un des leurs depuis 10 ans qui
s'engagent et se donne corps et âmes
pour leur territoire ce sont nos
associations nos bénévoles la France
c'est 68 millions de Français de
l'Hexagone des outrem et de l'étranger
qui n'ont pas fini de nous surprendre
dans un monde où tout
s'accélère où tout se transforme je
refuse avec eux que notre identité
puisse se diluer ou se dissoudre la
France a son rang à tenir sa voix à
faire entendre sa singularité à imposer
nous avions nous avons une fierté
française à maintenir une fierté
européenne à consolider affronter pour
avancer les difficultés économiques les
boulevercement climatique démographique
géopolitique ne nous figeront jamais ne
nous conduiront jamais à nous
perdre ne signifie pas la fin de tout
mais le passage d'un monde à l'autre un
passage difficile un passage douloureux
inquiétant à bien des égards mais un
passage que nous réussirons j'en suis
intimement convaincu à ceux qui veulent
y voir notre disparition j'y vois notre
renaissance parce que nous avons une
identité et des valeurs à ceux qui
veulent y voir un triangle des Bermudes
j'y vois notre caporne parce que nous
savons où nous voulons aller et que nous
y
arriverons à ceux qui veulent y voir
une perte de boussole j'y vois une
détermination parce que j'ai confiance
confiance parce que je connais le chemin
que nous avons parcouru depuis 2017 les
tabou que nous avons levés les obstacles
que nous avons
franchis j'ai confiance PL j'ai
confiance parce que je connais les
Français leur énergie leur volonté leur
créativité j'ai confiance parce que face
aux épreuves aux inquiétudes au crises
notre pays s toujours
relevé l'épidémie de covid a mis à jour
bon nombre de fractures dans notre
société elle a poussé notre modèle
social dans ses retranchements mais
notre pays a tenu et nous avons protégé
nos concitoyens mieux que beaucoup
d'autres l'ont
fait le dérèglement climatique nous
frappe plus dur plus fort plus souvent
l'exceptionnel devient la norme les
catastrophes se multiplient mais notre
pays agit avec force et jamais dans son
histoire les émissions de gaz à effet et
de CERN ont baissé aussi rapidement que
l'an
dernier la guerre en Ukraine a ébranlé
l'Europe elle a détruit le rêve d'une
paix éternelle sur notre continent elle
nous a rappelé durement que la
démocratie était fragile et la liberté
un idéal toujours à défendre mais notre
pays notre Europe ont montré le visage
de la détermination face à à l'agresseur
et sa solidarité pour le peuple
ukrainien
l'attaque terroriste monstrueuse en
Israël et la guerre au Proche-Orient on
on ravivé des PLA des mots jusque dans
notre société mais notre pays a su se
dresser répondre par le refus de la
haine et par l'unité la crise
énergétique l'inflation la menace
terroriste les crises se superposent
s'enchevêtre et s'additionne elle
n'offre aucune solution miraculeuse mais
méthodiquement avec les Français nous y
répondrons bien sûr face à ces crises
pour beaucoup de Français l'avenir estav
avantage une crainte qu'une promesse et
encore trop de Français ont le sentiment
de perdre le contrôle de leur propre vie
avec le président de la République avec
mon gouvernement je ne m'y résous pas je
ne m'y résoudrai
jamais pour tous c français nous allons
continuer à affronter pour avancer pas
par des belles paroles de grandes tirad
ou de beau discours mais par des actes
des actes rapides des actes concrets de
nouveaux changements dans leur vie et
sur le
terrain madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés sous l'git du
président de la République l'identité
même de cette majorité de ce
gouvernement c'est de reconquérir notre
souveraineté française et
européenne notre promesse au français
est claire oui nous voulons reprendre
notre destin en main en ouvrant une
nouvelle page de cette conquête nous
pouvons nous abuyer sur un bilan concret
tangible et solide en 2017 ma génération
n'avait connu que la
désindustrialisation qui semblait
inéluctable le chômage de masse qui
s'encrait l'Europe qui se désunissait la
transition écologique qui rimait avec
nécessité plus qu'avec réalité au fond
en 2017 la souveraineté de la France et
de l'Europe était pour beaucoup un
impensé pour certains même il s'agissait
d'un gros mot nous avons assumé de
parler de souveraineté et plus encore
nous avons assumé d'en faire la matrice
de notre action et nous avons agi nous
avons engagé une action résolue pour la
souveraineté économique avec pour la
première fois le retour de l'industrie
sur notre sol n'en déplaise au
Cassandre dans déplais au Cassandre il y
a désormais plus d'usines qui ouvre que
d'usin qui ferme en France plus emplois
industriel qui sont créés que d'emplois
industriels qui sont détruits en France
ça n'était pas arrivé depuis 30
ans notre taux de chômage est descendu à
un niveau jamais atteint depuis 25 ans
et pour la 5e année consécutive notre
pays le plus attractif d'Europe pour les
investissements
étrangers nous avons engagé une action
résolue pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et conquérir
notre indépendance énergétique avec une
planification écologique inédite dans le
monde et une stratégie énergétique pour
une énergie plus souveraine et plus
durable nous avons engagé une action
résolu pour la souveraineté de nos
frontières avec une loi immigration et
un Pact asile immigration au niveau
européen enfin réellement protecteur de
notre
pays nous avons engagé une action
résolue elle prendra du temps pour que
chaque française chaque Français puisse
garder le contrôle de sa propre vie qu'
ne soit jamais entravé jamais assigné
àés viidence jamais résigné et
évidemment nous avons engagé une action
résolue pour la souveraineté agricole de
notre pays mesdames et messieurs les
députés je le dis ici dès le début de
cette intervention notre agriculture est
une force pas simplement parce qu'elle
nous alimente au sens propre du terme
mais parce qu'elle cont constitue un des
fondements de notre identité de nos
traditions parce que nos agriculteurs
incarnent des valeurs fondamentales et
qui lorsqu'ils sont lorsqu'elles sont
bridées fragilisent l'ensemble de la
société je pense à la valeur travail à
l'effort et à la liberté
d'entreprendre notre agriculture est une
force et notre fierté aussi alors je le
dis ici solennellement il y a et il doit
y avoir une exception agricole française
je suis
lucide je suis lucide face à
l'empilement des normes face aux
décisions qui tombent d'en haut et qui
parfois tombent Donon ne sait où
l'agriculture doute elle aussi et elle
attend des réponses et des solutions
nous serons au rendez-vous sans aucune
ambigué madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés allez un peu de
silence s'il vous plaît devant vous je
prends la parole conscient de l'ampleur
de la tâche à accomplir je veux
m'adresser à tous les Français à ceux
qui doutent et à ceux qui espèrent à
ceux qui écoutent et à ceux qui n'y
croient plus je veux m'adresser à tous
ces Français souvent de la classe
moyenne toujours au rendez-vous de leur
responsabilité qui ne se plaignent pas
alors qu'ils ont souvent le sentiment de
subir à ces Français qui ont le
sentiment d'avoir tous les devoirs quand
d'autres ont tous les droits à ces
Français qui ont parfois le sentiment
que leur propre pays s'éloigne qu'ils
n'y ont plus vraiment leur place alors
qu'ils en sont le cœur battant à ces
Français de l'Entre Deux trop riches
pour bénéficier des aides mais pas assez
pour ne pas compter qui ont le sentiment
que les décisions se prennent sans eux
et qu'ell bénéficient toujours au
mêm
à ces Français qui ont parfois
l'impression de vivre dans une France
archipelle dont les ponts seraient sur
le point de rompre mais ces Français qui
espèrent au fond d'eux qu'on parviendra
à les réunir à ces Français qui ne
demandent pas la lune mais simplement à
pouvoir vivre de leur travail éduquer
leurs enfants se soigner et vivre en
sécurité je les entends je les comprends
et comme la majorité yuvre depuis 2017
veux contribuer à leur répondre je le
veux avec d'autant plus de détermination
que je sais le risque pour eux de les
laisser céder à des sirènes qui ne
conduirait qu'au chaos à la division et
à l'effondrement car je suis
lucide que pendant que nous agissons
certains guettes entretiennent les
colères et espèrent récolter les fruits
mesdames et messieurs les députés le
défi est immense et j'ai bien conscience
que nous ne pourrons pas le relever seul
avec mes ministres que je remercie pour
leur engagement sans
faille conscience aussi du message très
clair exprimé par les Français en 2022
nous avons une majorité que je salue à
qui je veux dire ma confiance et ma
fidélité mais cette majorité est
relative et les Français attendent que
nous cessionions les querelles de
principe pour échanger et pour agir
ensemble depuis 2000 depuis 2022 depuis
18 mois sur bien des textes nous y
sommes parvenu et aujourd'hui je le dis
à la majorité comme aux oppositions nous
avons la France en partage je le crois
un devoir commun de transcender les
clivages les désaccords et les divisions
pour vrer au service des
Français évidemment nous ne serons pas
d'accord sur tout évidemment nous nous
opposerons dans cet hémicycle et
ailleurs mais je vous le dis je ne
renoncerai jamais à dialoguer ma porte
sera toujours ouverte parce qu'à travers
vous mesdames et messieurs les députés
des oppositions ce sont les voix de
millions de Français qui s'expriment
même si je ne suis pas convaincu que ces
millions de Français attendent qu'on
cherche à couvrir son interlocuteur par
des cris pendant qu'il intervient dans
les de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est aussi cela la méthode
que je veux pour mon gouvernement
respecter les Français respecter les
oppositions respecter notre Parlement je
m'y eng gage j'en serai le garant ma
méthode a toujours été la même français
porte une vérité sur notre pays nous
devons l'écouter et y répondre force
politiques organisations syndicales élus
locaux français depuis ma nomination
j'ai entamé des échanges toujours avec
franchise et lucidité alors avec vous je
veux chercher à faire raisonner les mots
de nos concitoyens répondre à leurs
inquiétudes et porter leurs espoirs
alors Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
ma priorité est claire favoriser le
travail pour que ceux qui en sont
éloignés s'en rapprochent en soutenant
ceux qui n'ont que le fruit de leur
travail pour vivre et qui sont toujours
au rendez-vous de leur
responsabilité mon CAP est clair c'est
celui de la souveraineté et de
l'indépendance à l'échelle individuelle
nationale et européenne ma méthode est
claire elle reste la même dire les
choses dire la vérité même quand ça fait
mal même quand ça nous conduit à
remettre en cause nos propres décisions
dire la vérité donc et agir agir
vraiment agir maintenant madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés parler au français c'est au fond
entendre quatre appels à l'action pour
le travail pour qu'il paye mieux et
toujours plus que l'inactivité partout
et pour tous pour nos services publics
pour qu'il soi accessible et de qualité
partout et pour tous pour l'autorité le
civisme le respect des droits et devoirs
partout et pour tous pour un
environnement plus respirable partout et
pour tous et je veux l'affirmer nous
n'avons pas à renoncer aux grandes
conquêtes et à la création de droits
nouveaux mesdames et messieurs les
députés pour le travail pour nos
services publics et le rétablissement de
l'autorité dans notre société pour la
transition écologique nous partons
aujourd'hui d'un bilan solide derrière
le cap fixé par le président de la
République nous avons multiplié les
actions et les réformes et je veux
rendre ici hommage à l'action
déterminante d'Édouard Philippe Jean
Castex et Elisabeth borne dont le sens
de l'État et la détermination à faire
sont des
exemples je veux rendre hommage à la
majorité toujours pour améliorer le
quotidien des Français je veux saluer
tous les parlementaires qui ont accepté
de sortir des logiques partisanes pour
permettre l'adoption de nombreux
texte aujourd'hui les résultats sont là
depuis 2017 nous avons montré que le
chômage de mche n'était pas une fatalité
nous avons engagé des réformes fortes
qui avaient été trop longtemps
repoussées nous avons pris les
ordonnances travail dès le début du
premier quinquena nous avons mené une
réforme de l'assurance chômage une
réforme de l'apprentissage une réforme
des retraites nous avons lancé le
contrat d'engagement jeune baisser les
impôts et les charges et engager une
réforme majeure du lycée professionnel
aujourd'hui le chômage a baissé de 2
point 2 millions d'emplois ont été créés
notre industrie revient avec 100000
emplois industriels créés et la
réouverture de 300 usines le nombre
d'apprentis à plus que triplé ils sont
désormais plus de 850000 en France et
nous avons le cap du million en
vue depuis 2017 nous avons agi
massivement pour nos services publics
pour notre santé avec les 19 milliards
d'euros du Ségure de la santé avec une
revalorisation historique des soignant
l'augmentation du nombre de places en
études de médecine d'infirmiers d'êt
soignants pour notre école nous avons
engagé des transformations majeures et
agit pour l'égalité des chances je pense
au dédoublement des classes ou encore à
l'augmentation du salaire des
enseignants la plus forte depuis 30
ans pour notre sécurité nous avons
investi comme jamais par le passé 10000
postes de policiers et gendarmes ont été
créés lors du premier quinena 8500 de
plus le seront lors de celui-ci et nous
avons lancé la création de 238 brigades
de gendarmerie nouvelle la sécurité ça
doit être pour tous y compris dans la
ruralité et dans les petites
villes depuis 2017 17 pour la planète
nous avons préféré au grands mot les
vrais actes nous agissons et nous
agissons plus qu'aucune majorité avant
nous avant 2017 les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre baissaient d' 1 % en
moyenne en France dans le premier
quinena elles ont baissé de 2 % en
moyenne en France l'an dernier sur les 9
mois les 9 premiers mois de l'année
seulement elles ont baissé de près de 5
% c'est le crédit de notre action sur la
transition
écologique et conformément à
l'engagement du président de la
République nous avons désormais une
stratégie complète secteur par secteur
territoire par territoire la
planification écologique nous nous
donnons les moyens de réussir et nous
investissons cette année 40 milliards
d'euros pour la transition écologique
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés nous avons
beaucoup fait mais il reste encore du
chemin alors avec mon gouvernement je
suis prêt je suis déterminé nous devons
répondre aux inquiétudes de la classe
moyenne et faire en sorte que ceux qui
vont travailler puissent vivre dignement
de leur travail et gagnent toujours plus
que ceux qui ne travaillent pas nous
devons répondre au défis des emplois non
pourvus car il est incompréhensible que
le chômage reste autour de 7 % alors
qu'il y a tant d'entreprises et de
filières qui cherchent à recruter
partout sur le territoire
national nous avons en France un
paradoxe nous avons un C minimum un SMIC
nettement supérieur à celui de nos
voisins et nous en sommes fiers mais
nous avons une part de nos travailleurs
proches du SMIC beaucoup plus
importantes que nos voisins c'est un
problème d'abord nous agirons résolument
pour que les banches professionnelles
qui continuent à rémunérer en dessous du
SMIC remontent ses rémunérations c'était
le cas d'une soixantaine d'entre ell
l'été dernier grâce à la mobilisation
engagée alors nous étions descendus à
une trentaine à la fin de l'année 2023
la revalorisation du SMIC au 1er janvier
dernier on a fait redescendre une partie
en dessous du SMIC je demande de
poursuivre et amplifier la mobilisation
pour des résultats rapides et je
n'exclus aucune mesure pour y
parvenir
ensuite nous devons faire évoluer un
système qui nous a conduit je le disais
il y a un instant depuis des décennies à
concentrer nos aides nos exonérations au
niveau du SMIC aujourd'hui pour
augmenter de 100 € le revenu d'un
employé au SMIC l'employeur doit
débourser 238 € de plus quant au
salariés il perd 39 € de prime
d'activité il voit sa CSG et ses
cotisations sociales augmenter de 26 %
et il rentre dans l'impôt sur le revenu
en bref autant le dire notre système
fruit de réformes successives prpéterie
de bonnes intentions ces dernières
décennies a placé notre monde économique
dans une situation où il n'y a quasiment
plus aucun intérêt pour quiconque à
augmenter un salarié au Smic on ne peut
accepter une France où beaucoup sont
condamnés à rester proche du SMIC toute
leur
carrière la progression
salariale toujours permettre de
récompenser l'effort et le le mérite
alors oui j'assume de le dire il faut
désmicardiser la France dès le prochain
projet de loi de
finances en nous appuyant sur les
propositions de parlementaires de
partenaires sociaux et sur un certain
nombre de travaux d'experts qui sont
actuellement conduit nous commencerons à
réformer ce système dans le même temps
nous devons continuer à baisser les
charges qui pèsent sur la classe moyenne
après la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation de la redevance télé la
baisse de 5 milliards d'euros des
premières tranches de l'impôt sur le
revenu nous tiendr l'engagement du
président de la République d'une
nouvelle baisse d'impôt de 2 milliards
d'euros cette baisse d'impôt sera
financée et la solidarité nationale
devra s'exercer pour nos classes
moyennes valoriser le travail ce n'est
pas seulement pour les salariés nous
agirons aussi pour nos fonctionnaires
qui permettent à l'état d'avancer et
s'engage au service de l'intérêt général
en intégrant leur mérit et leurs efforts
à leur rémunération un projet de loi
sera déposé dès le second semestre de
cette année
nous agirons pour nos indépendants tous
nos commerçants nos artisans nos
agriculteurs qui sont indépendants en
2026 nous aurons réformé l'assiette
sociale des indépendants cela veut dire
plus de droit notamment à la retraite
sans payer davantage de cotisation c'est
l'engagement de cette
majorité deuxième objectif pour réussir
je veux déverrouiller l'accès au travail
déverrouiller notre société je veux
permettre à tous ceux qui le peuvent de
travailler avec en tête les droits et
les devoirs de chacun le droit d'être
mieux accompagné grâce à la réforme de
France travail mais aussi le devoir de
chercher un emploi dans 18 départements
nous avons lancé une expérimentation qui
conditionne le RSA à 15h d'activité pour
l'insertion je vous annonce que nous
généraliserons ce dispositif à tous les
départements de France d'ici le 1er
janvier
2025 de plus nous devons aller plus loin
dans la réforme de l'assurance chômage
une négociation a été lancée en faveur
de l'emploi des seniors de la prévention
de l'usure professionnelle des parcours
et des reconversions et nous souhaitons
qu'elle aboutisse à un résultat
ambitieux mais la situation économique
évolue parce que nous gardons notre
objectif de plein emploi et que nous
devons inciter toujours plus à la
reprise du travail je serais extrêmement
attentif à l'évolution de la trajectoire
financière de l'assurance chômage si
cette dernière dévit je n'hésiterai pas
comme la loi le permet à demander aux
partenaires sociaux de remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier sur la base
d'une nouvelle lettre de cadrage aux
ambitions très claires inciter toujours
plus à la reprise d'emploi sans aucun
tabout nous assumerons également de
combattre toutes les trappes à
inactivité d'un côté en rendant les
droits effectifs nous avons été capable
de faire le prélèvement à la source nous
serons capables de mener à bien le
chantier de la solidarité à la source
pour éviter marche inutile garantir la
justice sociale pour que chacun touche
l'intégralité de ce à quoi il a
droit combattre les trappes à inactivité
c'est permettre le droit effectif de
chacun grâce à la solidarité à la source
et je l'assume c'est aussi assumer de
réinterroger notre modèle je pense
notamment à laallocation de solidarité
spécifique qui prolonge indemnisation du
chômage et qui permet sans travailler de
valider des trimestres de retraite nous
avons une conviction cohérence forte
nous considérons que la retraite doit
être le fruit du travail et donc nous
proposerons la bascule de l'allocation
de solidarité spécifique Ra et la
suppression de cette allocation chercher
un modèle social plus efficace et moins
coûteux ce n'est pas un gros mot c'est
un
impératif déverrouiller le travail c'est
aussi l'adapter aux nouvelles
aspirations de nos concitoyens c'est un
fait le rapport au travail a changé je
mesure dans ma génération comme dans les
autres les changements de mentalité les
nouvelles attentes sur les horaires sur
la disponibilité sur l'équilibre entre
vie professionnelle et vie familiale ces
aspirations ne doivent pas être niées
elles ne doivent pas être caricaturé non
plus au risque de décevoir certains ici
personne ne demande un droit à la
paresse dans notre
pays non ces aspirations elles doivent
être regardé pour ce qu'elles sont notre
rpport travail c'est notre rapport au
temps à l'équilibre personnel on ne peut
pas appliquer les mêmes calques
génération après génération les attentes
changent les technologies évoluent et
font apparaître de nouvelles fractures
je pense notamment à celle entre ceux
qui peuvent télétravailler et ceux qui
ne peuvent pas télétravailler alors les
conditions de travail doivent aussi
évoluer et l'État doit donner l'exemple
comme ministre des comptes publics
j'avais décidé
d'expériment d'expérimenter dans mon
administration non pas la semaine de 4
jours mais la semaine en 4 jours sans
réduction du temps de travail à certains
endroits il y a eu peu de candidats je
l'avoue à d'autres ils sont nombreux à
avoir choisi de pouvoir arriver plus tôt
le matin partir plus tard le soir pour
travailler un jour de moins comme
premier ministre je demande à l'ensemble
de mes ministres d'expérimenter cette
solution dans leurs administrations
centrales et déconcentré
oui l'État doit donner l'exemple
s'agissant de l'organisation du travail
notamment pour toutes ces personnes qui
travaillent dur et qui se sentent
invisible je pense notamment aux
personnes du ménage parfois forcé à
faire des heures de transport en commun
au milieu de la nuit tout ça pour éviter
qu'elle ne travaillent en même temps que
les salariés et qu'elle croisent les
agents qui sont dans les bureaux là
aussi je veux que l'État montre
l'exemple et que désormais dans l'état
les personnels d'entretien de
l'administration qui le souhaite puisse
travailler aux mêmes horaires que tout
le monde c'est-à-dire aux horaires de
bureau nous devons mieux prendre en
compte notre rapport au temps et
nouserons à avancer dans le chantier du
compte ép temp universel véritable sac à
dos social qui doit permettre à ceux qui
le souhaitent de travailler beaucoup
plus silence s'il vous plaîtes chers
collègues juste un peu de silence il un
Brou continue je vous remercie de bien
vouloir monsie dinton merci Monsieur le
Premier Ministre je pense madame la
Présidente qu'ils ont compris que je ne
m'arrêterai pas malgré leur hurlement et
donc je peux continuer sans aucune
difficulté mieux prendre en compte notre
rapport au temps et nous continuerons à
avancer dans le chantier du compte épin
de temps universel je l'ai dit il y a un
instant véritable sac à dos social qui
doit permettre à ceux qui le souhaitent
de travailler beaucoup plus à certains
moments de leur vie où ils le peuvent
notamment quand ils sont jeunes et n'ont
pas encore de responsabilité familial
pour pouvoir ensuite à d'autres moments
de leur vie travailler moins pour
développer un projet pour s'occuper de
sa famille
déverrouiller notre économie c'est aussi
conquérir de nouvelles liberté refuser
le principe de rente être capable de
continuer à transformer et libérer un
projet de loi en ce sens sera examiné au
printemps il permettra notamment de
déverrouiller certaines professions
comme les syndic ou encore les ventes en
ligne de médicaments par les pharmacies
mesdames et messieurs les députés
beaucoup d'entre vous me l'ont dit s'il
est un secteur qu'il faut déverrouiller
c'est bien le logement le problème du
logement est clair il tient à la fois à
l'offre et à la demande or pouvoir se
loger acquérir son logement c'est pour
tant de Français le projet d'une vie
l'assurance d'une retraite sereine en
lien avec les élus locaux nous
répondrons à cette crise du logement en
créant un choc d'offre avec cinq
solutions immédiates
proposées d'abord nous allons simplifier
massivement les normes revoir les DPE
simplifier l'accès mapre Renov faciliter
la densification lever les contraintes
sur le zonage accélérer les procédures
ensuite nous désignerons dans 2 semaines
20 territoires engagés pour le logement
où nous accélérerons toutes les
procédures comme nous avons su le faire
pour les Jeux Olympiques et
Paralympiques avec pour objectif d'
créer 30000 nouveaux logements d'ici 3
ans nous n'hésiterons pas à procéder à
des réquisitions pour des bâtiments
vides notamment des bâtiments de bureau
nous l'avons déjà fait et N nous
continuerons à le faire nous
continuerons à soutenir le monde du
logement social nous avons agi pour lui
en maintenant le taux du livra avec 1,2
milliard d'euros pour leur rénovation
énergétique avec des plans de rachat
massif nous voulons également répondre
aux causes structurelles de la crise du
logement social le coût élevé du foncier
avec un nouveau prêt de très long terme
2 milliards d'euros distribué par la
banque des territoire et nous allons
aussi contribuer à faire évoluer le
monde du logement social le faire
évoluer pour inciter les élus à
développer de nouveaux programmes aussi
je vous annonce que nous allons donner
au maire la main pour la première
attribution dans les nouveaux logements
sociaux construit sur leur communes
c'était une mesure attendue par les élus
locaux nous allons aussi engager un
chantier une réflexion pour faire
évoluer le logement social pour qu'il
réponde davantage aux classes moyennes
vous le savez d'ici 2025 toutes les
communes soumises à la loi SRU doivent
posséder au moins un/art de logements
sociaux sur leur territoire nous
proposerons et nous mettrons en débat
d'ajouter pour une part les logements
intermédiaire accessible à la classe
moyenne dans ce calcul des 25
%. mesdames et messieurs les députés des
smicardisé pour promouvoir le travail
déverrouiller pour libérer la croissance
je veux aussi débureaucratiser la France
je veux alléger
le fardeau des règles et des normes qui
pèsent sur ceux qui créent nos TPE et
nos PME sur tous ces Français qui
travaillent sans compter et qui créent
de l'activité et de l'emploi il a été
évalué que chaque année ce sont 60
milliards d'euros que nous perdons à
cause des démarches et des complexité de
notre quotidien aussi nous engagerons
après l'été une nouvelle étape de la
réforme du droit du travail avec un
objectif clair libérer nos TPE et nos
PME simplifier considérablement leur
quotidien et leur permettre de négocier
certaines règles directement entreprise
par entreprise mais cet élan de
simplification ne doit pas se limiter au
travail partout dans notre pays les
Français me racontent combien les normes
les oppressent les brident les empêchent
de faire et d'avancer je pense à nos
agriculteurs évidemment je pense à tous
les petits patrons je pense à nos élus
locaux qui croulent sous les règles et
les procédures
administratives à date à date le nombre
de mots pour dire des normes sur légif
France s'élève à 44,1 million de mots
c'est pratiquement deux fois plus qu'il
y a 20 ans à tous les échelons il faut
déburaucratiser la
France nous évaluerons les normes qui
peuvent être supprimées ou simplifiées
avec les Français avec les
professionnels avec les élus nous
regarderons les démarches qui peuvent
être améliorés tous les sujets sont sur
la table mon seul objectif c'est de
libérer les Français dans leurs
initiatives c'est de les laisser vivre
et respirer supprimer des normes c'est
possible vendredi dernier j'ai annoncé
la suppression de 10 premières normes
nationales pour nos agriculteurs et
beaucoup d'autres suivront au niveau
local en Haute Garonne en quelques
réunions sur une semaine la semaine
dernière le préfets et les agriculteurs
se sont accordés sur l'abrogation de
quatre arrêtés préfectoraux cette
logique est étendue dès cette semaine à
l'ensemble des départements
français
simplifier les démarches c'est possible
et je vous annonce que dès cette année
chacun pourra enfin porter plainte en
ligne partout sur le territoire
simplifier pour éviter simplifier pour
éviter la gabgie c'est possible et je
vous annonce une nouvelle une nouvelle
règle générale simple tous les organes
tous les organismes tous les comités ou
autres qui ne se sont pas réunis ces 12
derniers mois seront supprimé par règle
générale
enfin enfin dépend entier de notre
économie demande des simplifications
encore drastiques notamment pour
accélérer le retour de notre
industrie pourquoi parce que trop de
délais c'est moins de projet et donc
moins d'emploi et moins de croissance
quand un investisseur veut implanter un
projet en Europe quelque chose lui saute
aux yeux France il faut 17 mois en
moyenne pour implanter un projet
industriel en Allemagne c'est deux fois
moins ça ne peut pas
continuer avec le projet de loi
industrie verte nous avons marqué une
première étape je vous annonce que nous
déposerons un deuxième projet de loi
industrie verte il proposera notamment
de demander à la CNDP de concentrer ses
travaux uniquement sur les projets
d'envergure national ce sera 6 mois de
gagner dans les procédures pour les
autres projets
la bureaucratie qui reculule c'est la
liberté qui avance je veux libérer les
Français des contraintes qui les
freinent et sont autant de boulets pour
notre économie madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
déverrouiller désmicardisé
déburaucratisé oui mais dans un seul
objectif réarmer notre pays je veux le
dire d'emblé le préalable du réarmement
de la France c'est la responsabilité
budgétaire nous devons faire preuve
d'une responsabilité exemplaire dans nos
finances publiques il en va de notre
souveraineté il en va de la survie de
notre modèle social il en va de la
protection des plus
fragiles de la protection des classes
moyennes qui seraient les premières
victim des coupes massives et des
hausses drastiques auxquels nous serions
contraints si nous ne tenons pas notre
trajectoire de réduction des déficits et
de notre dette et je le dis pour nous le
meilleur moyen de réduire nos déficits
ça restera le travail et la croissance
pour certains la croissance est un gros
mot et pour cela on a que le mot taxé à
la bouche tout y est passé dans les
propositions parlementaires ces deux
dernières années j'étais au première
loges en tant que ministre du Budget
vous avez voulu taxer les heures
supplémentaires des ouvriers le
patrimoine des retraités et même les
successions des petits agriculteurs à
cela je le réaffirme quand on taxe tout
très vite il n'y a plus rien à taxer et
on ne taxe plus rien du
tout
je vous confirme que nous poursuivrons
le même cap repasser sous les 3 % de
déficit public d'ici 2027 grâce à plus
de croissance plus d'activité à la
maîtrise de nos dépenses pas grâce à
trop d'impôts grâce à des économies de
structure aussi nous mettrons toutes nos
forces dans la bataille nous allons
poursuivre et renforcer les revues de
dépenses auxquel tous les ministères et
tous les secteurs de l'action publique
seront associés les premières
propositions d'économie pour le prochain
PLF issu de ce travail seront annoncé
dès le mois de mars et je souhaite
qu'ell donne lieu très vite à des
échanges avec la représentation
nationale madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés ce réarmement
que nous construisons avec le président
de la République il a un objectif
prioritaire assumer notre souveraineté
alors oui nous continuerons à renforcer
notre souveraineté nationale et
européenne où nos frontières doivent
être respectées la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale doit continuer à
s'intensifier il faut assumer
d'accueillir moins pour accueillir mieux
nous continuerons à déployer la border
force lancé dans les alpes maritimes qui
a déjà permis plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'interpellations à la
frontière italienne je tiendrai
l'engagement de ma prédécesseur de
réformer l'aide médicale d'État nous le
ferons avant l'été par voie
réglementaire avec une base qui est
connue le rapport evvin
stéphanini défendre notre souveraineté
nationale c'est aussi donner les moyens
N
à nos armées pour protéger nos
territoires et nos valeurs nos
militaires se battent au péril de leur
vie pour défendre notre pays et notre
République et dans le cadre de la loi de
programmation militaire nous tiendrons
nos engagements vis-àis d'ux en de
quinen nous aurons doublé le budget du
ministère de la
défense avec vous tous avec vous toutes
je veux rendre hommage aux femmes et aux
hommes de nos armées rendre hommage à
ceux qui sont tombés pour n défendre
leur sacrifice nous oblige notre
reconnaissance est
infinie notre souverain
c'est aussi notre capacité à répondre au
besoins de nos concitoyens et donc sur
ces fondements nous allons réarmer nos
services publics ils ont toujours été
une fierté ils doivent le rester et pour
certains d'entre eux le redevenir nous
allons continuer à réarmer notre système
de santé et avec vous je veux rendre
hommage à tous les soignants de France
chacun à leur poste chacun dans leur
spécialité Ils sont les visages de
l'engagement de
l'accompagnement de l'attention et de
l'humanité
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui quel est le
problème malgré le travail de nos
soignants le temps médical manque un peu
de silence nos compatriotes ne trouent
pas suffisamment de médecins et les
délais aux urgences se rallongent cela
se traduit par la désertification de
notre pays et par la saturation de nos
de nos hôpitaux et en particulier des
urgences l'objectif est clair plus de
temps médical premier pilier agir pour
qu'il y ait plus de médecins devant les
Français les effets de la suppression du
numérus closus ne se feront pas sentir
immédiatement alors nous devons mettre
en œuvre des solutions fortes tout de
suite c'est pourquoi comme l'a annoncé
le président de la République nous
procéderons à la régularisation des
médecins étrangers sur notre
territoire
c'est pourquoi aussi je vous l'annonce
je nommerai un émissaire chargé d'aller
chercher à l'étranger des médecins qui
voudrai venir exercer en France et nous
devons trouver les moyens de faire
revenir nos jeunes Français qui sont
partis étudier à
[Applaudissements]
l'étranger nous devons aussi nous devons
aussi et c'est ce qu'a proposé le député
noer mieux reconnaître l'expertise et la
volonté de soignants qui ont fait
beaucoup d'études et qui ont une vraie
expérience une infirmière anesthésiste
qui a un bac+ 5 plusieurs années de
carrière et d'expérience elle doit
pouvoir si elle le souhaite rentrer
directement au moins en 3è année de
médecine pour devenir médecin si elle le
souhaite deè pilier agir pour qu'il n'y
ait aucun territoire oublié nous avons
depuis 2017 déployé le service d'accès
aux soins le sas il permet un progrès
notable dans l'accès aux soins non
programmés je l'ai vu encore récemment à
Dijon dès cet été chaque département
devra être doté d'un service d'accès aux
soins avec des professionnels organisés
pour assurer la permanence des soins
dans les départements où il n'y aurait
toujours pas de service d'accès aux
soins et de réponses satisfaisantes je
suis prêt à aller plus loin en
restaurant des obligation de garde pour
les médecins libéraux en soirée ou le
weekend dans leur cabinet à l'hôpital ou
en maison de
santé trè pilier libérer les médecins
pour qu'ils se concentrent sur le soin
nous poursuivrons les chantiers que nous
avons engagés notamment pour
l'attractivité de tous les métiers du
soin nous allons accélérer le passage de
6000 à 10000 assistants médicaux qui
permettront aux médecins de pouvoir se
concentrer son consacrer d'avantage aux
patients et moins en formalité
administrative concrètement cela
représente 2 millions et demi de cons
supplémentaire libéré tous les ans pour
les patients ensuite nous allons
poursuivre notre action en faveur de
l'hôpital les moyens du sgure de la
santé ne sont pas encore arrivé partout
ces lourdeurs ces lenteurs sont
insupportables cela changera rapidement
enfin il y a encore aujourd'hui trop de
rendez-vous médicaux qui ne sont pas
honorés pour les médecins il est
insupportable d'avoir chaque jour des
patients qui ont un rendez-vous et qui
ne se présente pas pour les Français il
est insupportable de savoir que des
millions d'heures sont perdus alors
alors qu'ils attendent parfois des mois
pour un rendez-vous je souhaite un
principe simple qui se traduise par des
mesures claires dès cette année quand on
a rendez-vous chez le médecin et qu'on
ne vient pas sans prévenir on
paye protéger nos concitoyens c'est
aussi les accompagner à tous les âge de
la vie et à toutes les étapes de la vie
nous continuerons à agir pour l'enfance
notamment l'enfance en danger nous eront
à bâtir une société où chacun peut
vieillir dignement comme il l'entend en
facilitant le maintien à domicile de
ceux qui le souhaitent et en améliorant
le quotidien en épade le défi humain et
financier est immense et nous avancerons
ensemble mesdames et messieurs les
députés parler de santé c'est trop
souvent oubli la santé mentale le
mal-être les dépressions les pensées
suicidaires ont beaucoup progressé chez
nos jeunes je veux faire de la santé
mentale de notre jeunesse une grande
cause de notre action gouvernementale
avec lài
des mesures claires et
immédiates d'abord réformer le
dispositif mon soutien PSI il faut être
lucide ce dispositif partait d'une bonne
intention mais il n'a pas donné les
résultats escomtés il faut avoir le
courage de le reconnaître même si c'est
nous qui l'avons mis en
place je vous annonce donc que nous
allons le rénover de fon en comble nous
allons augmenter le tarif de la
consultation remboursée pour limiter au
maximum le reste à charge pour les
jeunes patients et leurs familles et
pour lever tous les verrous nous
permettrons aussi aux jeunes d'avoir
accès directement au psychologues pris
en charge sans nécessairement passer par
un
médecin de plus nous allons mailler
notre territoire de maison départemental
des adolescents il y en a 50 aujourd'hui
je souhaite qu'il y en ait une par
département dans notre
pays pour la santé et notamment à la
santé psychologique les infirmières
scolaires sont des relais essentiels
auprès des élèves elles accomplissent un
travail remarquable elles accompagnent
les jeunes avec disponibilité écoute et
soin nous devons recruter davantage
d'infirmières Scola et mieux reconnaître
leur
engagement aussi je vous annonce et
c'est grâce à un amendement porté par
cette majorité un budget supplémentaire
dans le dernier PLF que j'ai décidé de
verser aux infirmière scolairire en mai
prochain une prime exceptionnelle de 800
€ et de revaloriser leur salairire de
200 € net par mois à compter de cette
date je demande également au
gouvernement de travailler à des
revalorisations pour les autres
personnels sociaux et sanitaires en
milieu scolaire madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
renforcer nos pouvoirs publics c'est
aussi agir pour notre école je veux ici
rendre hommage à nos professeurs ils
s'investissent tous les jours au service
de notre école de nos él et donc de
notre
pays j'ai souvent dit ma fierté d'être
leur ministre et aujourd'hui comme
premier ministre je n'oublie rien de ce
que nous leur devons et je serai
toujours à leur côté je l'ai dit sur le
Peron de l'hôtel de
[Applaudissements]
Matignon
je l'ai dit sur le pon de l'hôtel de
Matignon dès mes premières minutes comme
premier ministre l'école et la mer des
batailles sur l'école là aussi il faut
partir de la réalité des faits et pas
uniquement des classements
internationaux il suffit d'écouter ce
que nous disent nos français et
notamment les parents et les
grands-parents que nous disent-il que
ces dernières décennies le niveau a
baissé que si le nombre d'heures
d'absence remplacé à triplé ces derniers
mois le compte n'y est toujours pas que
nous disent les professeurs qu'ils
croient en leur métier mais qu'il est de
plus en plus difficile à exercer qu'ils
ont parfois peur d'enseigner dépend
entier de notre histoire et de notre
littérature que nous disent les jeunes
qui envisagent de devenir enseignants
que la formation initiale telle qu'elle
est organisé ne correspond pas à leurs
attentes et freine leur
vocation nous allons continuer à leur
répondre pour élever le niveau des
élèves j'avais lancé le choc des savoirs
il doit maintenant se déployer le choc
des savoirs c'est assumer que tout le
monde ne progresse pas au même rythme
que tout le monde n'a pas les mêmes
facilités ou les mêmes difficultés la
décision du redoublement sera désormais
à la main de l'équipe pédagogique et les
groupes de niveau commenceront à se
mettre en place dès cette année dans nos
collèges parce qu'une école du passage
automatique où l'on glisse de classe en
classe sans vérifier si on a le niveau
pour passer dans la classe supérieure
c'est une école où tout le monde stagne
où le niveau baisse nous assumons de
porter une école des savoirs de
l'exigence de l'excellence où chacun
apprend à son
rythme améliorer les savoirs c'est
évidemment aussi agir sur la question
des remplacements nous évaluerons le
pacte enseignant et si de nouvelles
mesures s'imposent nous les prendrons
veiller au niveau des élèves c'est
réagir face au nouveau défis qui les
menacent les écrans sont une catastrophe
éducative et sanitaire en puissance nous
avons d'ors et déjà interdit le portable
au collège et comme l'a annoncé le
président de la République nous
travaillerons à mieux réguler l'usage
des écrans dans et en dehors de l'école
pour nos
enfants j'ajoute qu'une école des
savoirs c'est aussi une école qui permet
de se projeter dans l'avenir désormais
tous les élèves de Seconde devront faire
un stage de 2 semaines nous continuerons
à rapprocher l'école de l'entreprise des
métiers des administrations des
associations une école qui fonctionne
c'est une école où nos professeurs sont
mieux formés nous réformerons la
formation initiale des enseignants pour
construire les écoles normales du 21e
siècle cette réforme sera présentée
d'ici au mois de
mars une école qui marche c'est aussi
une école où les élèves sont heureux
trop longtemps le bien-être des élèves
est resté un impensé le résultat nous le
connaissons ce sont notamment les drames
du harcèlement notre stratégie contre le
harcèlement qui a permis de briser des
tabous majeurs et très concrète
désormais c'est l'élève harceleur qui
doit quitter l'école plus l'élève
victime qui subissait la double peine je
suis fier que nous ayons décider de ce
changement le bien-être à l'école c'est
aussi donner toute leur place aux élèves
en situation de handicap bâtir une
société inclusive est au cœur des
priorités de mon gouvernement cela vaut
dans tous les domaines j'y suis très
attentif nous accompagnerons nos
concitoyens en situation de handicap en
toutes circonstance nous leur
simplifierons la vie nous prendrons
intégralement charge le remboursement
des fauteuils roulants de ceux qui en
ont besoin comme nous y sommes
engagés nous agirons partout et
particulièrement à l'école depuis des
années l'État et les collectivités se
renvoient la balle sur la prise en
charge des aesh sur la posuse du Midi
résultat dans beaucoup d'endroits
personne ne le finance et la conséquence
c'est une double défaite des élèves qui
ne sont pas suffisamment bien accompagné
au moment du repas et des aesh qui ne
peuvent pas faire un temps complet pour
améliorer leur rémunération
il faut sortir de cette situation où
chacun se renvoie la balle je prends une
décision claire l'état prendra ses
responsabilités et financera désormais
l'accompagnement des enfants en
situation de handicap sur le temps du
déjeuner en lieu et place des
collectivités
locales c'est un enjeu de solidarité de
dignité et de reconnaissance réarmer
l'école c'est réaffirmer nos valeurs car
je crois que la transmission du savoir
est impossible sans respect de
l'autorité sans respect de nos valeurs
républicaines au premier rang desqueles
la laïcité on ne négocie pas avec la
République on l'accepte on la respecte
en entier sans ma sans la moindre
exception c'est pourquoi nous déploirons
l'expérimentation de l'uniforme à
l'école symbole d'égalité républicaine
et comme l'a annoncé le président de la
République expérimentation et
conclliante nous généraliserons
l'uniforme en France à la rentrée 2026
je veux le dire également je ne peux pas
me résoudre à ce que certains
professeurs craignent d'aborder certains
chapitres du programme à la moindre
entorse à notre pacte républicain il
doit y avoir des décisions fortes et des
sanctions fermes et cela doit nous
conduire à revoir l'échelle des
sanctions dans nos établissements
scolaires pour ne rien laisser
passer mesdames et messieurs réussir le
réarmement civique c'est au cœur des
priorités de mon gouvernement nous
devons faire respecter l'autorité
partout dans les classes dans les
familles dans les rues ce respect
s'apprend à l'école je le disais mais ce
respect passe aussi par les familles les
violences de juillet dernier ont
profondément marqué notre pays parmi les
émetiers des très jeunes très jeunes
parfois qui semblaient avoir déjà coupé
les ponts avec notre société qui ne
respectent plus leurs parents pour qui
la violence semble un moyen comme un
autre de tromper l'ennui je ne me
résoudrai pas à ce qu'on a préfère
attendre avant de donner une lourde
peine alors que bien souvent c'est très
tôt qu'il aurait fallu agir nous devons
disposer de sanctions adaptées pour les
mineurs de moins de 16 ans pour eux on
ne peut pas aujourd'hui prononcer de
peines de travaux d'intérêt général je
vous annonce que nous créerons des
travaux d'intérêt éducatifs qui seront
leur équivalents et seront donnés plus
facilement que des peines d'intérêt
général cela fera partie cela fera
partie de la révision de l'échelle des
sanctions dans nos établissements
scolaires que j'évoquéis il y a un
instant dès le plus jeune âge il faut en
revenir à un principe clair tu casses tu
répares tu ses tu nettoies tu défies
l'autorité on t'apprend à la
respecter nous responsabiliserons aussi
davantage les parents dans le cadre du
projet de loi sur la justice des mineurs
nous soutiendrons la mise en place de
travaux d'intérêt général pour les
parents de jeunes délinquants qui se
sont totalement et volontairement
soustraits à leurs obligations et
responsabilités parentales mais je le
dis il est hors de question d'accabler
certaines familles quand on est une mère
seule de plusieurs enfants dans un
quartier on peut-être totalement dépassé
par les événements et on n'est pas
toujours responsable de la dérive de ces
enfants pour elle au contraire cette
dérive est un échec et une douleur
terrible nous devons les aider
et je ne me résous pas à ce que nous
ayons une situation où nous ayons des
familles dépassées par les événements
avec des enfants qui ne respectent pas
nos règles et qui sont violents d'un
côté et 50000 places d'internat
disponible de l'autre nous y répondrons
désormais quand un jeune sera sur la
mauvaise pente plutôt que de les laisser
plonger dans la délinquence nous
proposerons aux parents de le placer en
internat en y facilitant l'accès y
compris financier nous allons le coup de
ces mauvaises fréquentations nous allons
lui offrir un cadre un enseignement une
chance le réarmement civique c'est bien
entendu le respect de la loi nos
concitoyens attendent de nous que nous
agissions encore et toujours contre les
violences contre les trafics contre les
cambriolages contre l'insécurité du
quotidien et la délinquence il demande
de l'ordre dans nos rues tout n'est pas
une question de moyens il faut fa les
mettre au service d'une stratégie plus
offensive encore comme l'a dit le
président de la République nous allons
doubler la présence policière dans les
rues d'ici à 2030 nous allons mener des
actions coordonnées de tous les services
de l'État forces de l'ordre éducation
services sociaux dans certains quartiers
c'est le sens des force d'action
républicaine nous les déploierons dès la
fin du mois de février dans trois
premiers territoires à Maubeuge à
Valence et à Besançon contre
l'insécurité nous nous sommes fixés deux
priorités la lutte contre les
stupéfiants et la lutte contre la
délinquence du quotidien en particulier
les
cambriolages nous allons encore monter
d'un cran dans notre combat contre la
drogue en mettant en uvre un nouveau
plan de lutte contre les stupéfiants
notre stratégie de harcèlement et de
pilonnage contre les dealers porte ses
fruits nous avons réussi à faire
disparaître un/art des points de Deal
alors nous allons poursuivre avec 10
opérations place net par semaine nous
devons aussi taper les dealers au
porte-monnaie et leur couper les vivres
c'est pourquoi nous allons désormais
geler les avoirs des trafiquants de
drogue qui sont
identifiés
notre réarmement civique passe par une
justice plus rapide et plus efficace
ensemble nous allons envoyer un message
clair l'impunité c'est fini nous avons
décidé de moyens exceptionnels pour
notre justice ils seront en rendez-vous
pour accélérer les délais nous allons
améliorer le fonctionnement de la
justice avec plus de magistrats plus de
greffiers avec une organisation plus
respectueuse de nos concitoyens et une
nouveauté désormais les Français ne
seront plus convoqués sur des créneaux
pouvant courir sur une -journée entière
mais sur un créneau horaire bien défini
c'est aussi par ce type de mesure et de
preuve de respect que l'on renoue le
lien entre la justice et les
justiciables
enfin notre réarmement civique c'est
renforcer l'unité républicaine de notre
jeunesse c'est permettre à tous les
jeunes de France de faire nation c'est
le rôle même du service national
universel je lance les travaux en vue de
sa généralisation à la rentrée
mesdames et messieurs de les députés
parler de nos services publics c'est
aussi parler de nos territoires chacun
n'a pas les mêmes défis les mêmes
attente les mêmes besoins j'évoquerai
demain longuement devant le Sénat la
stratégie sur les territoires je veux
d'ors et déjà ici puisque vous êtes
aussi élu de circonscription et pour un
bon un bon nombre d'entre vous élus
locaux comme moi vous dire quelles sont
nos attentes mon gouvernement sera
toujours à l'écoute des territoires et
des élus locaux toutes les solutions se
construiront avec eux je peux vous
assurer aussi que nous cherchons
toujours des solutions adaptées aux
réalités du terrain en ayant recours à
la différenciation à l'adaptation
desnmes nous continuerons à avancer
c'est le sens de la mission confiée à
Eric vert qui nous remettra ses
propositions dans les prochains mois
nous chercherons ensemble un chemin pour
une autonomie de la Corse dans la
République comme s est engagé le
président de la République alors que je
parle de différenciation de territoires
j'ai une pensée pour les territoires
d'outr-em où elle s'impose tout
particulièrement y réarmer nos services
publics il est peut-être plus crucial
plus vital encore qu'ailleurs les
outremers sont un atout déterminant pour
notre pays il y a dans chaque territoire
d'outr-emè l'enthousiasme de notre
jeunesse la détermination à réussir
l'avenir mais nos outremers concentrre
aussi tous les défis contre la vie chère
pour l'emploi pour la sécurité pour la
santé l'école la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale et la transition
écologique chacune de nos politiques
publiques doit tenir compte des
spécificités outre j'y tiens et pour
faire face aux enjeux exceptionnels
auxquels son territoire est confronté
nous déposerons une loi sur Mayotte je
veux ici avoir un mot particulier pour
la Nouvelle-Calédonie je souhaite que le
processus politique en cours aboutisse
j'y veillerai et vous examinerez dans
quelques semaine un projet de loi
constitutionnel sur l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
ensemble je vous propose d'accélérer
encore notre transition écologique le
dérèglement climatique ce ne sont pas
seulement quelques degr gr de plus ce
sont des vies détruites par les
intempéries ce sont des exploitations
agricoles menacées et avec elles toute
notre capacité à nous nourrir ce sont
des maisons et des immeubles menacés par
la montée des eaux fissurés par les
mouvements des sols face à ces constats
certains voudraient une écologie de la
brutalité pour eux l'écologie doit être
punitive douloureuse passer par la
désignation de Bou émissaire et par la
décroissance la décroissance je le redis
ici c'est la fin de notre modèle social
c'est la pauvreté de masse jamais je ne
l'accepterai
je crois au contraire qu'on ne fera pas
l'écologie contre le peuple je crois au
contraire qu'il faut entendre les
inquiétudes des Français de tous les
Français il faut entendre les
agriculteurs qui travaillent et qui
s'inquiètent pour leur avenir et leur
métier il faut entendre les élus locaux
qui veulent développer leur communes il
faut entendre les millions de Français
des villes moyennes des petites commune
et de la ruralité pour qui la voiture
égage de travail et de
liberté
l'écologie sans le peuple c'est pavé le
chemin aux crises social et au
renoncement au contraire nous allons
continuer à bâtir ensemble une écologie
populaire une écologie à la française
avec les Français pour les Français
c'est le sens de la planification
écologique qui protègera la biodiversité
et permettra une baisse radicale de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre une
baisse de 55 % d'ici
2030 une écologie populaire c'est une
écologie où chacun agit à la hauteur de
ses moyens c'est pourquoi l'État sera
exemplaire c'est pourquoi nous
continuerons d'aider les entreprises à
participer activement à l'effort je suis
fier que les 50 sites industriels les
plus émetteurs 50 sites qui
représentaient à eux-mêm 10 % de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
France se soi tous engagés à réduire
leurs émissions de près de moitié d'ici
2030 et je vous annonce je vous annonce
que nous lancerons une initiative
similaire contre la plti pour les 50
sites qui mettent le plus d'emballage
plasti sur le
marché une écologie populaire c'est une
écologie des solutions le président de
la République s'était engagé à lancer
une offre de véhicule électrique pour
moins de 100 € par mois cet engagement
est tenu et le succès est déjà au
rendez-vous le président de la
République s'est engager à développer
les r métropolitain à investir
massivement dans le FERR vert cet
engagement lui aussi nous tiendront une
écologie populaire c'est une écologie de
la croissance et de l'emploi le retour
de l'industrie les investissements en
faveur de la décarbonation grâce à
France 2030 les métiers de la rénovation
thermique ou le secteur de l'économie
circulaire oui la transition écologique
regorge d'opportunités de secteur en
croissance de filières nouvelles oui
nous ferons rimer climat avec
croissance une écologie populaire c'est
une écologie qui se construit au plus
près des réalités des Français et des
territoires des concentrations des
concertations sont en cours partout en
France au côté des élus locaux nous
donnerons à chacun les moyens de le
faire et je souhaite que le financement
de leurs plans locaux de transition
écologique soit établi partout d'ici
l'été une écologie populaire c'est une
écologie qui protège et assure notre
souveraineté grâce à la sobriété aux
énergies renouvelables au nucléaire nous
allons assurer notre indépendance
énergétique je veux le dire sans
ambiguïé là aussi il faut être clair le
nucléaire est une fierté
française le nucléaire c'est un atout
majeur pour notre pays j'assume d'être à
la tête d'un gouvernement pro énergie
nucléaire avec une majorité pro énergie
nucléaire qui me
soutient nous allons continuer à en
puissance
dereéaire tir massivement dans les
programmes cette année le Pr de
flamandville sera opérationnel c'est
aussi grâce au nucléairire que nous
pouvons garantir les meilleur prix aux
Français nous protégerons mieux les
consommateurs et régulerons les prix
d'électricité afin qu'il se rapprochent
des coûts de production et nous
continuerons à développer les énergies
renouvelables de la même manière que
nous développerons le nucléaire dans
notre pays
enfin mesdames et messieurs les députés
bâtir une écologie populaire c'est
répondre aux aspirations de notre
jeunesse réussir i écologique et le défi
de notre génération notre jeunesse veut
s'engager participer aider elle le fait
déjà beaucoup d'ailleurs elle se demande
parfois comment être utile pour la
planète c'est pourquoi nous lancerons un
service civique écologique qui
rassemblera d'ici à la fin du quinquena
50000 jeunes prêts à s'engager
concrètement pour le
climat j'ajoute j'ajoute que si nous
devons réduire nos émissions et protéger
notre biodiversité nous devons aussi
nous adapter au dérèglements climatiques
nous adapter c'est nous préparer c'est
veiller à ce que chacun même les plus
fragiles soi prêt face au ravage du
dérèglement climatique nous présenterons
dès ce trimestre un nouveau plan
d'adaptation au changement climatique il
présentera des solutions adaptées à
chaque territoire notamment dans les
outr M enfin je vous annonce que nous
ferons évoluer le régime de catastrophe
naturelle pour le moderniser et éviter
que certains assureurs n'abandonne les
territoires les plus à
risque
enfin je l'ai déjà évoqué j'y reviens
nous devons mener notre réarmement
agricole produire et protéger pour notre
souveraineté voilà mon approche depuis
2017 nous avons engagé ce combat de la
souveraineté et du revenu c'est le sens
des plans de filière des différentes
loisigalim du varen de l'eau nous avons
débloqué 250 millions d'euros pour
trouver des alternatives au
phytosanitair c'est un effort inédit sur
l'Union européenne nous avons toujours
été moteur sur la réciprocité et les
closuses miroir et nous les ferons
respecter produire produire produire oui
ça vous dérange produire produire c'est
d'abord donner du temps à nos
agriculteur pour passer plus de temps
dans leurs champs moins de temps devant
leurs écrans produire c'est être
souverain je souhaite que cet objectif
de souveraineté alimentaire soit
désormais clairement inscrit dans la loi
protéger aussi protéger face aux crises
climatiques et sanitair le gouvernement
l'a toujours fait lors du gel des
sécheresses de la grippe avière nous
avons adopté un budget de l'assurance
récolte sans précédent avec un budget
historique nous continuerons à le faire
protéger face à la concurrence déloyale
c'est le combat pour la réciprocité et
pour les mesure miroir que je vais
continuer à mener avec détermination ce
combat il doit se mener en Europe comme
nous l'avons fait sur les médicaments
vétérinaires mais nous devons aller plus
loin changer de logique j'assume de dire
que tout ne sera pas réglé en quelques
semaines j'assume de dire que les
chantiers sont complexes et que pour
certains il faudra y travailler encore
j'assume aussi d'apporter des réponses
rapides part tout là où c'est possible
très concrètement sur égalim dès la
semaine dernière 100 inspecteurs de la
DGCCRF supplémentaire ont commencé leur
contrôle sur le terrain qui seront deux
fois plus nombreux qu'auparavant c'est
une vague de contrôle sans précédent sur
la trésorerie des exploitants nous
avançons dès à présent dès février 50 %
des remboursements TICPE seront versés
aux exploitants soit 733 € par exemple
pour une exploitation utilisant 7000 l
de GNR dès la semaine prochaine 5
février précisément un guichet pour la
prise en charge des frais vétérinaires
concernant la MHE sera ouvert il
permettra de verser les premières
indemnisations dès la fin du mois de
février le taux de prise en charge des
frais vétérinaires a été révalué à 90 %.
d'ici le 15 mars toutes les aides PAC
seront versé sur les compes bancaire des
exploitants et nous travaillerons avec
les
régions et nous travaillerons avec les
régions pour que les aide à
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
puissent être versés dans les prochaines
semaines pour certains cela fait plus
d'un an qu'ils attendent et la semaine
dernière le fond d'urgence Bretagne a
été doublé sur la simplification j'ai
parlé du travail tout à l'heure des 10
premières normes du travail au niveau
local nous allons poursuivre et nous
irons plus loin encore et tout ce que
nous pouvons le faire faire dès
maintenant nous le ferons d'ors et déjà
je peux vous dire que nous avons avancé
ces derniers jours dans la discussion
dans l'échange avec les agriculteurs et
leurs représentants sur une série de
sujets
sur l'élevage nous avons mis en œuvre un
dispositif fiscal qui leur permet qui
doit leur permettre de faire face à
l'inflation notamment sur les prix de
leur bê nous le renforcerons pour
protéger toujours davantage nos éleveurs
sur Galim là c'est très clair j'ai déjà
parlé des amendes et des contrôles mais
je peux vous dire que toutes les les
amendes qui seront infligées à
l'industrie à la grande distribution
seront réutilisé pour soutenir
financièrement nos
agriculteurs sur la viticulture sur la
viticulture oui nos viticulteurs
souffrent mais notre filière viticole et
notre fierté elle fait rayonner la
France et donc je vous annonce que nous
allons développer dans les prochains
jours des moyens nouveaux avec un fond
d'urgence avant la fin de la semaine
pour soutenir nos viticulteurs
particulièrement en
xitamie sur les contrôles je lance
aujourd'hui un grand plan de contrôle
sur la traçabilité des produits
l'objectif est clair garantir une
concurrence équitable notamment pour que
les normes qu'on applique aux ur soit
aussi respecté par les marchandises
étrangères au niveau
européen nos trois priorités immédiates
sont clair les JCH les importations
ukrainiennes notamment de volaille et le
mercosour ces sujets seront portés et
sont portés très fortement par le
gouvernement et le président lui-même
nous nous sommes engagés nous avons
engagé une coalition de 22 pays sur la
question desj ch et nous sommes proches
d'aboutir à une nouvelle prolongation de
la dérogation nous ne nous laisserons
pas faire nous prendr toutes les mesures
pour éviter toute surtrposition d'où
qu'elles viennent je le sais nous ne
sommes pas au bout du chemin il y aura
de nouvelles conquêtes dans les jours
qui viennent je pense notamment aux
jeunes agriculteurs à la transmission
des exploitations mais nous agissons
vite fort avec détermination et respect
pour nos
agriculteurs madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
réarmer la France c'est continué à
conquérir de nouveaux droits le
président de la République a fait de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
la grande cause de ces quinquen
elle sera au cœur des engagements de mon
gouvernement c'est le sens de la réforme
du congé parental annoncé par le
président de la République aujourd'hui
le congé parental ne laisse pas assez de
revenus aux familles bien souvent il est
inégalement réparti dans le couple
éloigne durablement les femmes de
l'emploi alors comme toutes les
inégalités nous devons la combattre
aussi le congé parental sera transformé
en congé de naissance de 6 mois mieux
rémunéré que les parents pourront se
répartir entre eux conquérir de nouveaux
droits c'est reconnaître et défendre
sans relâche le droit des femmes à
disposer de leur corps nous inscrirons
le droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse au sein de notre texte
fondamental de notre
Constitution conquérir de nouveaux
droits enfin c'est être au côté de nos
concitoyens jusqu'au bout de la vie la
fin de vie est sans doute l'une des
questions les plus intimes et les plus
délicates qui soit c'est se pencher sur
son histoire c'est repenser aux
souffrances enduré par certains
c'est s'interroger sur soi-même sur ce
que l'on voudrait face à l'insupportable
et à l'irréversible face à l'irréparable
on ne peut légiférer sur la fin de vie
qu'avec une grande prudence grande
retenue et un grand respect aujourd'hui
nos compatriotes clairement nous appelle
à revoir notre droit c'est une demande
des familles c'est une demande des
malades c'est un appel grave auquel nous
devons répondre nous y répondrons nous
renforcerons considérablement les unités
de soins dans notre pays avec une unité
par département avant l'été nous
examinerons un projet de loi sur l'aide
active à mourir dans notre pays ce débat
animera notre société je le sais je
souhaite qu'il puisse se tenir dans une
volonté d'équilibre et dans le respect
des convictions de chacun madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés je viens de tracer les grandes
orientations que suivra mon gouvernement
en suivant ce chemin je propose aux
Français d'avoir pleinement le contrôle
sur leur vie je souhaite que la France
retrouve pleinement la maîtrise de son
destin qu'elle soit pleinement
souveraine une souveraineté industrielle
technologique et
numérique créatrice d'innovation et
d'emploi une souveraineté énergétique
qui nous protègera des crises protègera
l'environnement et garantira des prix
plus bas aux Français une souveraineté
agricole qui nous permettra de nourrir
notre pays avec les meilleurs produits
d'assurer l'avenir de notre agriculture
et dans les toutous prochains jours
j'aurai des annonces supplémentaires à
faire sur le sujet une souveraineté
culturelle où notre création notre
patrimoine sont soutenus où notre
exception culturelle est protégé où la
culture est enfin accessible à tous
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
parle de souveraineté nationale mais
c'est aussi par l'Europe que nous
parviendrons à la
consolider depuis 2017 et le discours de
la Sorbonne du président de la
République l'Europe a changé elle a
surmonté les crises pris ses
responsabilités c'est grâce à l'Europe
que nous avons pu avoir des vaccins face
à l'épidémie grâce à l'Europe que nous
avons bénéficié du plan de relance
massif c'est grâce à l'Europe que nous
soutenons l'Ukraine depuis le premier
jour face à l'agression russe grâce à
l'Europe que nous avons imposé des
normes au géants du numérique grâce à
l'Europe que nous avons instauré un
impôt minimal sur les grandes sociétés
multinationales pour lutter contre
l'optimisation fiscale grâce à l'Europe
que nous contrôlerons mieux nos
frontières grâce aux pacte asile
immigration un pacte que je résume en
une phrase nous contrôlerons enfin qui
peut entrer dans l'espace et qui ne le
peut pas grâce à l'Europe aussi que nous
investissons massivement dans certains
secteurs stratégiques et pour notre
industrie je le dis ceux qui prôent la
fin de l'application des traités sont
les partisans d'un frexit déguisé qui
affaiblirait la
France
moins d'Europe moins d'EUR c'est moins
de puissance pour la France je ne
prendrai qu'un exemple il fera mal à
certains ici le brexit ces partisans
promettaient des jours heureux à
l'économie britannique et au peuple
anglais la semaine dernière à cause du
brexit les derniers ha fourneau de
Grande-Bretagne ont fermé on ne produit
plus d'acier au Royaume-Uni nous en
France au contraire notamment grâce aux
investissements de l'Europe l'industrie
revient
qui était qui étai les premiers
partisans en France du brexit qui a
baptisé dans les villes qu'il dirige des
rues ru du brexit qui s'est affiché
ouvertement avec le leader du camp du
brexit c'est le rassemblement
national l'Europe l'Europe éternel
boucémissaire de ceux qui fautent de
pouvoir diriger un pays veulent détruire
tout un continent pas un Français ne
pense que nous pouvons nous passer
d'Europe pas un français non plus ne
pense que l'Europe a su pleinement
trouver la juste place dans sa vie ils
ont raison tout n'est pas parfait il
reste des chantiers à am mener mais les
faits sont là avec l'Europe notre
puissance est démultipliée et ces
dernières années nous avons commencé à
la
changer
et je le dis solennellement à l'heure où
il est minuit Mo- une dans le siècle
face aux imp impérialisme les masques
devront tomber on peut vouloir changer
l'Europe pour l'intérêt du pays et nous
le faisons mais on ne peut pas vouloir
sortir de l'Europe sauf à avoir d'autres
intérêts sauf à servir un autre pays une
autre
puissance
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés voilà les grands
principes qui guideront mon action celle
de mon gouvernement pour la France et
pour les français pour notre France qui
n'a jamais perdu son ambition de
grandeur pour ces Français qui n'ont
jamais manqué à leur devoir ces axes que
je vous ai présenté ils sont une réponse
aux enjeux de la nation probablement pas
la seule mais le reflet de l'ambition
que nous p avec le président de la
République il correspondent aussi au
rêve qu'une génération avait appris à ne
plus porter trouver un emploi stable
acheter un logement fonder une famille
faire des sacrifices mais acceptables
s'ils servent à l'ascenstion de leurs
enfants aimer les paysages une culture
commune une société libre et tenue dans
une époque si difficile il n'y a pas de
réponse simple mais il y a des espoirs
tranquilles à raviver j'assumerai
toujours toujours de débattre avec vous
je respecterai toujours vos opinions vos
propositions je ne rejetterai jamais la
critique tant qu'elle est constructive
ces mots ces mots je les adresse à vous
je les adresse aussi aux Français je
sais leurs attentes je sais qu'ils ne me
pardonneront rien les temps sont
troublés les doutes sont nombreux mais
l'espoir est
là la France est puissante parce que ce
qui nous réunit est toujours plus fort
parce que la France notre pays notre
nation notre terre demeureront notre
fierté parce que oui être français en
2024 oui c'est une fierté notre société
est plus ouverte plus audacieuse plus
pionnière que l'image que nous nous
renvoyons parfois à nous-mêmes être
français en 2024 c'est vivre dans un
pays où l'histoire s'écrit être français
en 2024 c'est vivre dans un pays qui n'a
pas renoncé au progrès social à protéger
les droits de tous et surtout de toutes
et en conquérir de nouveau être français
en 2024 c'est vivre dans un pays dont
l'honneur est de se battre pour la
stabilité du monde pour la justice et
pour la paix être français en 2024 c'est
dans un pays qui il y a 10 ans seulement
se déchirit encore sur le mariage pour
tous pouvoir être Premier ministre en
assumant ouvertement son
homosexualité de tout cela je vois la
preuve que notre pays bouge la preuve
que les mentalités évoluent la preuve
que nous n'avons aucune raison de céder
à la fatalité alors je n'ai qu'une chose
à dire à nos concitoyens quel que soit
leur couleur de peau leur origine leur
adresse leur croyan la France est votre
pays et en France tout est possible
madame la Présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés oui nous sommes
fiers d'être français et avec vous je
veux faire briller cette fierté
française je viens de vous présenter le
cap de mon gouvernement le cap price ous
l'autorité du Président de la République
pour reprendre pleinement notre destin
en main et restaurer notre souveraineté
et aujourd'hui nous sommes prêts prêts à
voir la vérité en face prêts à écouter
prêts à entendre la voix de tous les
Français prêts à agir prêt à euœuvrer
sans relâche fidèle à notre devise
républicaine prêt à garantir la liberté
à œuvrer pour plus d'égalité à toujours
choisir la fraternité parce que madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés nous ne sommes pas n'importe
quel pays nous ne serons jamais une
puissance moyenne qui se résignerait au
déclin avec fatalité nous ne sommes pas
condamnés à subir mais déterminés à agir
déterminé à prendre notre destin en main
déterminé madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés parce que nous
sommes la France et que rien ne résiste
au peuple
français